you had this whole tour plan that you
were going to do a get out the vote a
bunch of shows in battleground states
right before you know leading up to the
election you had the whole thing planned
do you think you could have made a
difference if you could have gone to
these towns
i think we are in a situation
where we need we
need to be coming together a year ago
we needed to come together on the
climate change issue
that is a huge thing and you almost
think well well
you know it's kind of happening slow
they're still kind of debating it like
it's a debate or like half the people
think this and half the people don't
it's like no
99 of the the scientists in the world
say this is happening and then you think
well
if it all happened in one day
then we would have to come together it
was like some life-changing thing where
it just happened in one day and we had
no way to avoid it
well that is what if you think about it
that's what's happened with this
pandemic
so now you've got a pandemic where you
really think
we would have come together
all of us regardless of you know
racism gender come together it takes a
special
person to
to [ __ ] that one up and turn it into
a something divisive in nature
where you know now mask wearing has been
politicized or you're anti-american and
i think that all americans
really really want the same thing i i
think most
humans want the same thing to be able to
raise kids to either you know
and have a job and and have a family and
listen to music and eat and [ __ ] and all
these things that we all have in common
you know the simple pleasures and
and maybe the ability to further
yourself and and further
the life for you know the next
generation if you have kids
that's all basic human needs i don't
it's to have been pitted against each
other
in this kind of way is has been um
so disheartening and and i'm
and it's maybe what's happened
on the positive side is that when you
see that 93 million people have
voted ahead of time maybe this is one
positive byproduct that people aren't
able to sit this one out and people are
getting engaged and hopefully
after the election they will continue to
be because there's just
you know so much work to do
and and so much to be repaired and and i
really
you know we talk about people reaching
across the aisle
you know in the senate or in the house
but i think people we need to reach
across the aisle
i mean i could not have said that better